e
[Musique]
rodriguez fiber l'état
durant cette visite au kenya le père
d'elizabeth le roi georges 6 meur
[Musique]
propulsant la jeune princesse sur le
trône à l'âge de 25 ans ce voyage en
afrique sera marquant
pour les moteurs à ce taux
la reine gardera une affection
particulière pour le kenya qu'elle
visitera trois fois à cette époque une
douzaine de nations africaines sont
encore les colonies britanniques les
années 1950 des années 1960 sont des
années où la question de l'afrique être
une priorité elle est au coeur de
l'actualité donc est-ce que c'est par
affection ou c'est pour défendre des
intérêts stratégiques importants peu
importe le résultat est là
quand elizabeth ii est couronné l'empiré
britannique est déjà pratiquement rayé
de la carte
durant la première moitié du 20e siècle
le royaume uni la salle et hooper la
plupart de ces colonies dont l'aisne en
1947 dans la mesure où certains états
notamment l'inde choisissent de devenir
d'épouser la forme républicaine mail
comme noël s'effrite dans une certaine
mesure parce que soudainement la
communauté d'intérêts est moins intense
en 1953 le cominois n'être que quatre
ans d'existence et ses pays membres la
jeune reine doit opérer une transition
délicate transformer l'ancien empire
colonial en regroupant libre de pays
souverains
australia and in flames of hand in game
of
thrones
début de son règne sa majesté prend
l'habitude de visiter régulièrement les
étapes son royaume en 1953 et 54 elle
fait une tournée de six mois dans une
dizaine de pays terminer dans la peur
75% des australiens seraient allés voir
la reine sur son parcours
mais ça reste un rôle symbolique les
symboles sont puissants et c'est clair
que lorsqu'on occupe des fonctions qui
sont pas politiquement déterminante on
peut quand même par des gestes par des
façons de manifester de l'intérieur
endroits de certaines choses avoir une
certaine influence
elizabeth ii se donne comme mission
d'utiliser toute la puissance du symbole
royal pour préserver les liens
économiques et politiques entre le
royaume uni et ses anciennes colonies
dans les années 60 elle déploie
plusieurs opération charme en afrique
pour convaincre les nouvelles nations
indépendantes de se joindre aux comme un
noir
[Musique]
en 1961 le ghana est indépendant depuis
quatre ans le président and chrome a
commencé à emprisonner ses opposants à
se rapprocher du bloc soviétique et
menace de se retirer du commonwealth le
premier ministre britannique jugent
qu'un voyage royal est trop risqué la
reine s'y rend quand même
c'était sûr aimant la visite royale n'a
plus controversées de l'histoire dit le
journaliste de bbc la reine à 11 jours
pour convaincre nkrumah de se rallier
aux communes wav président
sa majesté n'hésite pas paradis de
longues heures sous un soleil ardent aux
côtés du président controversé et même à
danser avec nous
[Musique]
des habits de est accueilli comme une
vraie star presque partout où elle
débarque comme ici à new delhi 12
millions d'indiens à que le convoi royal
pendant soixante ans elle va profiter de
cette affection du public pour
consolider le comme noir le faire
grandir
comme on peut le voir sur les photos de
famille de se mettre plus récent où le
prince charles est désormais invité
comme futur chef du commonwealth de sept
pays en 1953 l'organisation regroupe
aujourd'hui 54 états membres la reine
était toujours là chef d'état de 15 de
ces pays qu'on nomme les royaumes du
commonwealth le canada en fait partie
[Musique]
5 n'hésitez pas à les
financer
dans les quinze états qui reste il y
aura
dans la prochaine succession sera
hautement importante parce que chaque
état aura un peu à se remettre en
question ça posera inévitablement la
question on m'arrête où on continue le
décès d'elizabeth 2 pour et il a mené le
canada à abolir la monarchie
notre constitution très difficile à
modifier sera t'elle un obstacle si on
se limitait à un ordre du jour qui ne
portait que sur la monarchie et qu'une
réforme à coût nul au fond on
conserverait un chef d'état un
gouverneur qui aurait peu de pouvoir
mais qui jouerait au fond le rôle
nécessaire qui est le sien dans le
système parlementaire je pense qu'un
consensus serait possible
parce que l'attachement envers la reine
disparaîtra avec elle et que le prêt
charles beaucoup moins populaire les
abolitionnistes pourrait réussir à
rallier une majorité de citoyens et de
politiciens à l'idée de ne plus avoir
droit comme chef d'état